señoras y señores
un ambiente de libertad hubiera puesto
su plazo en el país el resultado de las
urnas del respeto y que hizo una cosa a
pesar de estas dos semanas y un métodos
desde a las brutales y violentos
similares a los que sufren los franceses
cotidianamente las ideas que
representamos
llegan hace una cumbre genes de final de
la segunda vuelta
el resultado de esta noche representa en
sí mismo de todas maneras una victoria
sorprendente
[Aplausos]
millones de nuestros compatriotas
escogieron el campo nacional y el cambio
así
expreso mi profunda gratitud a todos los
que me dieron su confianza en el primero
en la primera vuelta y a los que se
unieran a nosotros en la segunda vuelta
[Aplausos]
mis agradecimientos
especialmente a nuestros compatriotas de
las provincias y los campos y también a
los de el extranjero
y que me pusieron
que me hicieron ganar esta segunda
vuelta con una emoción que me honra
esta francia tan olvidada nosotros no la
olvidaremos
estamos más determinados que nunca y
nuestra voluntad de ayudar a los
franceses es aún mayor hoy en día no
tengo ningún resentimiento ni rencor
mil veces hemos encerrado la historia de
quienes
preveían nuestra desaparición pero está
en esta derrota de todas maneras siento
una forma de esperanza este resultado
constituye para nuestros clientes
franceses los siguientes europeos el
testimonio de un gran desafío del pueblo
francés sobre ellos que no pueden
ignorar y el de la aspiración
tan compartida de un gran cambio los
franceses manifiestan hoy el deseo de
contrapoder fuerte
al señor marco una oposición que los
seguirá protegiendo y defendiendo
frente a su pérdida de poder adquisitivo
a las amenazas a su libertad a los
servicios públicos del sistema social
cada vez más degradados
también frente a esa decisión sobre la
edad de la jubilación y el laxismo
judicial de hecho esta noche de
marketing en ato el quinquenio que se
abre no será diferente de la anterior y
pienso que el señor bajo no hará nada
para reparar las fracturas que dividen
nuestro país y hacen sufrir a nuestros
compatriotas para evitar este
acaparamiento de los poderes
seguiré mi compromiso por trans y los
franceses
con energía con perseverancia
y con el afecto que ustedes ya me
conocen
[Aplausos]
luego de esta secuencia presidencial
habrá una gran recomposición política en
el país al desaparecer los partidos
antes dominantes
y ante las élites autoproclamadas del
señor mal como una verdadera oposición
todavía la parte del partido no se ha
terminado porque pronto tendrán lugar
las elecciones legislativas
[Aplausos]
con el modo de votación de las
legislativas que falsea la
representatividad política
hay riesgo de que el señor mccone se
apodere de todos los poderes es un
riesgo alto es una perspectiva que
ningún patriota ningún demócrata puede
aceptar puesto que el proyecto del señor
mart font sobre lo soberano y lo social
sigue siendo
malo para francia destructivo para
francia quienes pretenden estar mañana
en la oposición al señor marco y sin
embargo quienes contribuyeron a
reelegirlo
y seremos nosotros los que con una
sinceridad intacta nunca transigiremos
con sus intereses por consiguiente esta
noche lanzamos la gran batalla electoral
de las legislativas
[Aplausos]
librar esta batalla al lado del señor de
la y con todos los que tuvieron la
valentía de oponerse al señor marco en
la segunda vuelta con todos aquellos que
tienen a la nación en su corazón
la agrupación nacional unirá a todos los
que quieran unirse y reunir sus fuerzas
contra la política de manuel marco con
el fin de presentar o apoyar a sus
candidatos en todas partes en el
continente en los departamentos de
ultramar
desde ya los invito a apoyarnos con
todas sus fuerzas y desde el 12 de junio
los invito a votar por todos ellos
recuerden amigos que no hay ninguna
fatalidad cuando los franceses
sí que observan su esperanza y se dan
los medios para defenderlos el resultado
histórico de esta noche nos planea nos
plantea las mejores condiciones para
continuar nuestra lucha queremos
ponernos al servicio de la mejor
ambición de todas de la única ambición
que realmente vale y estoy seguro segura
de que ustedes la comparten con nosotros
es
la única ambición que vale
[Aplausos]
esta noche
vuelvo y digo que nunca abandonaré a los
franceses viva la república vio a
francia
[Aplausos]